welcome to this video playing pointe du
jour pour du jour hi this is a good
score six out of seven this is shad
something to build upon I lost one game
though ok so the bogo with a night bd2
yeah i'm playing this pretty much i know
inside line with 26 but it's not not so
bad especially considering that it's
very little effort to learn let's see
you want some I'm coming here d5 yeah no
I cannot move the night yeah cause of
the Queen a4 check I need to give up the
bishop it's not a big deal though the
position is some very typical of the
bull go with them slight space
disadvantage but I have got f5 from
amongst others um I don't know should I
go a5 here takes 94 might be an idea but
yes God Bishop before ma it's may be
interesting let's try that ok it's not
looking at this at all night your former
I can do that yeah Knight e5 if I can do
take on d to always need to check those
kind of little tactics um ok I can even
take the two now if I want which would
be a simple solution Bishop f5 it's not
a good idea i guess f5 maybe not then
you might move the bishop let's just
take the bishop keep it keep it simple
okay I wonder maybe I should maybe just
stabilize the whole thing a bit and go
from here um ship to g4 maybe try to
exchange this you will probably move the
night but anyway I need to connect rooks
at some point so Bishop g4 cannot be
awfully bad I hope 91 maybe I played c5
that's surprising I mean it's not
terribly bad or anything but I thought
that preparing this would be a bit more
a bit more and beneficial probably so
what do I want here i would like to
exchange the heavy pieces this would be
a be rather helpful if i take it's not a
good at d IM to to grab upon him the
night is not very well placed on his
heaven i would really prefer to have it
on f6 if possible but how to hard to see
how to get it down Knight to g4 is not
not really working not quite sure I mean
this is fairly solid here what my
chances lie in a in a minor piece
endgame where it might be possible to UM
to to do something with the night
against the bishop which has some the
pawn on d5 that it always said just
looks into I have the slightly more
sound porn structure okay this is a very
very cheap trick
with rook takes and and so on but my
main point is not the cheap trick my
point is that I'd like to maybe am yeah
I need to connect rooks and maybe get
some counter play him
okay he decided to advance interesting
yeah i was just about thinking and maybe
I should take see fire but now it's
obviously a bit too late okay I go H
form take first I let's go edge for
retakes takes root b7 rook a1 kingi to
SF the serious counterplay oh
interesting and it looks this looks a
bit weakening maybe f5 around the corner
isn't this way to maybe take and then f5
maybe in 10 first here and then this 22
intent them to intend f5 and nigeria
nigeria so a threat now takes takes
Queen takes Bishop g2 age three and
black it sir it's very fine okay at 5
f-5 it also allows um yeah i can go in
and go in five it allows Luke and here
can take and play Queen f6 yeah this is
a problem for white I hope
let's got the check on the rook and g4
hangs so that's a double threat and I
don't know if he can allow me to take
you on g4 maybe you can play with guy
seven maybe takes take c7 this kind of
this kind of crazy line yeah possible
possible c7 has an important porn but
still if i go here if he takes here and
i give the check on a one he needs to
play Bishop f1 not sure that that's a
direct win not really time morning very
tough put a shack very tough position ok
Bishop f1 is the only move and then I
thought I capture intending maybe h2 on
IG form I only have 50 seconds difficult
something like Queen d3 might be coming
either check here but i have a check
here on there for you can go in the
corner I take d5 ok give that check 7
this is probably probably the way to go
and Queenie 6 check is it's basically
just a check it's not not directly
winning take I can take that if this
check here I'll start let's start with
this maybe
93 check yeah okay I've got 26 seconds
chat the biggest problem really Oh c7
I've a hard time to do anything against
that uh oh what a shame huh yeah okay my
time management killed me black eyes I
you know I cannot stop c7 length
queening it was certainly win for black
but where exactly can I h2 is I was just
winning odds this is very simple or with
38 seconds on the clock German hmm yeah
that's not really difficult I mean Jack
what I did is also clearly better for
blank but it's obviously not so easy
because of the sea porn this makes
things difficult here I'm losing rookie
70 rout g7 is even better but okay yeah
of course h2 of course h2 yeah that's
funny here HTG seems to be okay for
white the counter play on c7 s is really
strong it son tried remarkable only here
when he played this he lost again after
after Queen d4 here it is really losing
king h1 that's night and 5 this is a sad
senior that Queenie success is basically
a check just to check and now blacks
coming in with the far more serious
threats always the case you see the
complicated lines but Miss check the
kindergarten moves like H to check okay
thanks for watching